[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in
pat 40 unknown from sports illustrator
pat good morning
um i'm fired up about this but i
shouldn't be because this happens every
single year
can we get let me let me give you a poll
question here
you could have an 18 playoff
or we could just have the power five
conferences secede from the union
and they would have their own league
their own
you know guidelines their own
commissioner which one would you rather
have which one is more feasible
well that's a great question i think 18
playoff is is more feasible um
you know it would still end up with
seven at least power five teams in it
uh you know if they could if they could
make it eight for eight they would
but uh i you know i don't like the idea
of the power five splitting off because
i think that really jeopardizes the
basketball tournament
you know it it becomes two separate
entities really from the ncaa and maybe
that's what should happen but i just
think it'd become
then you could you could also easily
split off the basketball tournament and
further ruin college sports because then
you know butler doesn't get to go to a
final four against
uh uconn and against duke and that sort
of thing so
i i think i would prefer to see an 18
playoff with the
perhaps again still naive hope that they
would do the right thing and at least
be somewhat inclusive of somebody
outside the power five
all right who's gotten jobbed here in in
the college football rankings
well uh cincinnati absolutely has gotten
a job
coastal carolina's gotten a job
louisiana has gotten
wildly job byu has gotten jobbed
uh you could make a case that indiana's
gotten jobs as well but let's
concentrate on the teams outside the
power five that have had great seasons
for iowa state to be number seven with
two losses
in a league that completely flopped in
their one week where they tried to play
non-conference games the big 12
went 0-3 against the sun belt but the
two loss leader of the big 12
is six spots ahead of the undefeated
leader of the sun belt
and 12 spots ahead of the sun belt team
that beat
its butt in ames to open the season
it's just preposterous to me it's like
and i said in the column the default
setting
in god's sport says well the big 12 is
good well the proof on the field was
that the big 12 was not good when they
played somebody other than the big 12
but they still get rewarded because
we're used to saying the big 12 is good
so that's what just it frosts me to no
end that this is the way
things always work i mean cincinnati is
undefeated
has been statistically dominant has been
dominant in every game except for ucf
which is a pretty good team and they
pulled that game out
uh they lose they dropped back a spot
because they didn't play
i mean it's just it's it's it's
preposterous
i i would love to be in the committee
room so i could be throwing things at
them saying what are you doing
unfair or smart decision by big big ten
to allow
ohio state to play for the conference
championship a little bit of both if it
can be i mean ultimately it's a smart
decision and i do think
the one rationale that they expressed
makes sense that look even if they had
played this week and lost
they still would have won the east so
you you know you could go ahead and say
they i mean if you can say they are the
best team in the east without
having to you know stretch yourself very
far they beat indiana
uh now but again this is one more
example of
let's change the rules and let's change
the rules to favor
the favored sun which you know there had
this reason this season in the big ten
largely because ohio state
stood there on the table and said we can
win the national championship give us a
chance
so you know we're getting out to the
point where oh gosh by league protocol
league rules that we all agreed on
you're not going to win the big ten
championship i will just change that
so i i understand the frustration by
other people out there it looks like
more favoritism for ohio state it is
more favoritism for ohio state but
there's also some pragmatism
behind it can notre dame stay in the
final four
if they get blown out by clemson good
question
boy blowout it gets iffy obviously if
texas a m is sitting there with one loss
uh you know or if florida beats alabama
then then their their position is more
precarious you know if it's if they lose
by two touchdowns or less
i think they're you know and i i can
competitive with clemson but if they're
not if it's three
four touchdowns uh it's iffy for them
yeah i was wondering about ohio state
that they don't need to play another
game and they can still qualify for the
final four they're already in the four
top four that's why when social media
was like a
m and ohio state should play and i'm
like that only that's going to benefit
a m like ohio state's not moving up even
if they beat a
m uh but i wonder about that with
if florida would happen to win alabama
is still going to be in the final four
if clemson beats notre dame but not by a
lot then
those two schools are still going to be
in there that'd be your final four
and ohio state would be uh knocked out
yeah that would be the precarious
position for ohio state there you know
and i mean
it it it is important for if
just because that possibility exists
it's important for ohio state to play
the big ten title and look good i think
against northwestern because if florida
if florida beats alabama they're
probably going to get knocked out
because then
as you said florida's alabama clemson
beast notre dame in a close game
that's probably the way it is if alabama
beats
ohio state then yeah or i'm sorry
alabama beats four then ohio state
doesn't really need the other game as
you said the
no no teams undefeated teams lose ground
unless you're cincinnati
oh i know i'm howling at the moon with
this but i care
and i i just don't know if i'm just
being naive here
i mean well i i am i'm naive about it
because i actually thought
you know this year i thought going in
okay it's chaotic
two conferences two of the power five
conferences are only playing half as
many games as the other ones i don't
know whether we
they'll get consideration and then after
week one then the big 12
absolutely steps in it i thought well
the path is wide open
three of the power five conferences are
compromised to a degree
we just need one power one team from
outside the power five to be really good
and lo and behold here comes cincinnati
doing everything they need to do and you
get to the end it's like nah we're gonna
keep you behind these one lost sec teams
and oh no
now we're gonna move you behind the two
loss team from the big 12 even though
the big 12 sticks
uh keep fighting the good fight pat
thank you thank you
that's pat 40 his column uh
the 40-yard dash there on sports
illustrated